back when the internet was beginning to
boom and anime just started permeating
the international community I dare say
that no other anime made his biggest
impact as good old Naruto
pretty much everyone got captivated by
the ambitious ninja and his exploits so
for this video we're gonna go through
some of the best and most impactful
fights in the Naruto series so without
further ado let's get on with this video
team 10 spent part of an hour being
tangled with two prominent Akatsuki
members the zombie doer of headon and
kakuzu in their first big battle things
well they didn't go too well for the
good guys with our sumo fawning in
battle with that in mind the rest of
team 10 now temporary led by Kakashi
gave it one more try in the chaos of
things Shikamaru managed to isolate
himself against the immortal hidden
having decided that his best to isolate
the two Akatsuki members from one
another
the genius ninja would prevail after
trapping hidan for good while Naruto and
yamatoza rival even the odds against
kakuzu I personally would have preferred
it if Naruto didn't come at all with
that being said the fight is still one
of the best the series has to offer due
to the context and the amazing animation
in the anime
up next is number 9 on the list conan
vs. toby for all the time we spent as a
comic relief character the countdown to
the fourth ninja war gave us all a taste
of what Toby's truly capable of seeking
Nagato's Rinnegan toby begins his
mission of infiltrating the hidden rain
village and runs into the last remaining
member of Naruto's old fraction of
orphans
Coenen freshly turned against akatsuki
thanks to the encounter with Naruto
Coenen professes her resolve to defend
Naruto's corpse we've seen Conan's
repertoire before but she continues to
impress with her show of paper tag
powers against Toby in fact Toby seems
to be quickly overwhelmed by the barrage
of attacks and looks to be receiving an
easy defeat
villain hierarchy well that says no
actually with Toby still a raw character
shrouded in mysteries that have to be
revealed later we already know who's
gonna win and survive the battle in
spite of the outcomes predictability the
fight did give Cohen on a blaze of glory
before going out for good it also has
some of the highlights like the hidden
rains Village rain stopping for the
first time in the climax of the battle
warring on you Creek um
[Music]
Payne's Ark remains one of my favorite
arcs because of the amount of action and
twists it's got a lot of cool moments
such as the panes invading Konoha and
destroying it as well as the talk no
jutsu finale which i think is one of the
better applications of such storytelling
ultimately it's also thanks in large
part to this climactic fight seeing
Naruto return with his sage mode and
taking on pain gave a lot of you
goosebumps I'm sure the fight also
included some impactful moments such as
Hinata's brave Last Stand which
certainly showed a culmination of a
character development it also revealed
further advancements in Naruto's tailed
beast transformations pushing him to
power levels he'd never reached before I
really vowed with this fight to be one
of the best and the most impactful ones
because it ultimately serves as the
epilogue of a chapter in Naruto's quest
for glory his journeys not done not in
the slightest but as far as recognition
from Konoha goes our spunky and
ambitious ninja has finally climbed that
mountain after so much effort there's no
need or shisho usually to so marquee
motto Naruto
ask anyone who's watched Naruto about
what Jiraiya's most memorable battle is
and they'll tell you the tale of Jiraiya
the gallant you'll mostly get this fight
as an answer to that question and for
good reason to actually the legendary
sage spent most of his time in the
series as our hero's trustworthy mentor
even if he's a bit busy ogling girls and
doing all sorts of pervy things however
the gloves come off in his infiltration
mission and subsequent battle with pain
having already dispatched Conan Jiraiya
comes face to face with pain all forms
of him putting out all the tricks in his
bag
Jiraiya manages to hold out despite the
numbers disadvantage eventually he falls
to the sheer number of pains but not
before putting up one hell of a fight in
defeating multiple paths
despite his defeat Jiraiya was able to
smile in the end fully convinced that
while he failed his student would be
able to save the world
you didn't look or much guy in a cool
manner at all sweaty tuxes or email
sorry go a cop does it
[Music]
number six is naruto vs sasuke weight
which naruto vs sasuke are we talking
about here of course we start off with
their battle in the Sasuke retrieval arc
at the climax of the arc Naruto finally
catches up to Sasuke and begins their
destined fight after a long build-up to
their eventual battle the two had their
first major battle in this arc empowered
by the curse seals Sasuke shows himself
to be tougher than ever before
thankfully Naruto also had an ace up his
sleeve his nine tails powers that gave
him enhanced abilities not to be outdone
Sasuke Sharingan levels up in the battle
flipping the tide of the battle back to
his side in response naruto unlocks for
the first time his one-tailed
transformation a form which even Sasuke
ends up not being able to keep up with
so realizing that it's time for the
battle to come to an end Naruto and
Sasuke go after each other in one final
clash deliberately holding back from
delivering lethal blows in the process
when the dust settles Sasuke is revealed
to be the victor even with the power of
the nine tails naruto still fall short
of victory before we continue I'd like
to give a shout out to the sponsors of
this video grand summoners who are
bringing shield hero to your mobile
grand summoners is a game brought to you
by crunchyroll Games and it brings
players to an amazing RPG world full of
exciting battles taking the role of
Reyes the player gets to summon ancient
heroes in order to join the fight
against the demons in this epic anime
style RPG adventure game now what I
really like about this game is the
action-oriented responsive gameplay the
fact that there's a great balance of
difficult yet compelling battles that
you sometimes only win by just smear
points and the ability to customize your
party with equipment to mitigate any
weaknesses of less powerful units right
now they're collaborating with the
rising of the shield hero anime so by
just completing the first 10 exclusive
shield hero quests you can get your
hands on a limited time 5 star now for
me to join your ranks not only that you
can help him reach new heights by
completing even more advanced quests and
helping him level up to his true sixth
art form so what are you waiting for
download Grand summoners and get an
exclusive shield hero character now
Garcia / Vinnie tube or click the link
in the description
Sasuke returns for the fifth place entry
on the list with his fight against
Itachi
after several arcs of power-ups and
impressive victories against Orochimaru
Akatsuki members among others sasuke
finally gets his chance to exact revenge
the fight didn't disappoint in the
slightest
the brothers put on a show with their
spectacle of attacks each not willing to
be outdone by the other both combatants
left nothing on the table and even
unleashed never-before-seen techniques
on each other as ETSU watched on even
with all of his training sasuke still
seemed to be unable to defeat his
brother at the climax of the fight
Orochimaru
also had a surprise appearance towards
the end for thanks to Itachi's efforts
the sinister serpent ninja was defeated
for good moments before Itachi
himself died of exhaustion it's been his
motivation for the entire series and
Sasuke finally accomplishes his goal of
finally defeating his brother so why
then does this victory feel so empty for
our fallen hero hey even in defeat
Itachi still manages to give us an
emotional farewell while revealing a
sympathetic side to his story
[Music]
if you've got a few fights and chances
to prove yourself you better make damn
sure that you make an impact with those
few chances you have who knew that after
being a side character no more for
comedy might guy would come out in one
of his few fights and put on one of the
best shows in the entire series the
battle against Madara is highlighted
with guy finally releasing all eight
gates the culmination of his signature
technique
seeing as it's now Martha himself in
front of him guy doesn't pull back and
unleashes his full power in a scene that
many Naruto fans would remember for
years to come the fact that guy is
facing off against the guy who's
overcome everything thrown at him even
destroying an army with ease and even
look like he was winning for a part of
it just goes to show how powerful Rock
Lee's mentor really is guy even manages
to obliterate part of Martha's torsos
before succumbing to the use of all
eight gates obviously guy of all people
wouldn't be the one to put a mother a
down for good but he did pretty well for
himself now didn't Eve earning the
respect of one of the strongest ninjas
in history is one massive accomplishment
looks like guy was saving us all for
this one big fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I spent some time praising this fight
before and I'll do that again right now
Gaara versus Lee is by far one of the
best examples in Shonen anime of how to
properly write an underdog fight coming
into the fight no one knowledgeable
about anime writing hadley winning it at
all the arc villain who suspiciously has
a very similar background to the main
character is therefore our favorite
jumpsuit wearing ramen eating
protagonist to beat at the climax of the
arc still rock Lee's signature
determination prevents him from giving
up against the powerful opponent in
front of him using his taijutsu and the
8 gates technique Rock Lee proceeds with
his relentless assaults that made some
people suspend disbelief and think that
maybe just maybe Lee could do it
that's just how powerful a moment this
battle is this is the fight that put in
our Ruto on the map for a lot of people
and this is a fight that built up Rock
Lee as a serious contender in the Naruto
universe other anime can learn a lesson
or two on how to write an underdog fight
from this
second on the list and we have once
again
Kakashi versus Obito I've made many
videos that feature this fight and it's
no surprise that this fight finds its
way onto yet another list
Obito versus Kakashi for me isn't only
the culmination of one of the most
storied character plot lines in the
series not only is the battle a very
well built up one with an intense
backstory and hype it's also peak
hand-to-hand combat in Naruto the
animation team spared no expense here
and the flurry of exchanges got
encapsulated thanks to their hard work
make no mistake though the battle within
Kamui is a feast for the eyes and you'll
be missing out if you didn't watch it if
there's a fight to watch the entire
series of Naruto for in terms of
animation and pace that is this would
surely be one of those
Naruto and Sasuke meet once again at the
end of this list and fittingly their
fight at the end of the series is the
climactic culmination of the hero's
journey for so long the two have had
intertwined destinies and the final
battle to decide the better one is the
only right way for a story series to
reach its conclusion
Naruto's journey has been long and
filled with challenges and the one final
opponent he has encapsulate everything
against what he stands for at the peak
of their powers Naruto and Sasuke clash
for one last time Sasuke handily won
their battle at the valley of the end
and Naruto seems to have the upper hand
against his rival when they clashed once
again during the car gay summit arc this
final confrontation is more than a
conflict of strength although the anime
team made completely sure to shower us
with the fireworks in the eye candy
due to the combatants powers it's
ultimately a clash of ideologies and one
of the two rivals end up in a technical
draw with each other it's Sasuke who
voluntarily concedes defeat having his
heart of hatred overcome at last this
battle is one of the key moments in the
series and for me personally it's
responsible for the series ending with
the massive bang that it did and with
that we conclude the list and the
countdown featuring ten of the most
impactful fights in Naruto I'm sure that
some of you would have slightly
different rankings so I'd like to know
your thoughts on the topic and what you
think the most impactful fights are in
Naruto make sure you give the video a
like subscribe and hit the bell button
so you can stay updated as soon as
possible when we get new content like
this don't forget to check out our
sponsors game Grand summoners the links
in the description
[Music]